[Music]
this is the mall rats bumper sticker
from back in the day
get off your tail
gate and butt and go see our movie
put it on the back of the car kids don't
know what those are these days because
nobody goes anywhere kids there used to
be these things called cars and you
would put bumper stickers on the back of
them
okay arrow the good folks at
uh arrow films video man they uh
made this awesome mall rats blu-ray
uh they sent me a few i'm gonna open it
right now i'm not gonna watch it with
you because
i don't have a blu-ray player in this
room but let's unbox it you grab your
fat man beyond pen cut into
that plastic and we're unboxing things
when we were kids and you know up until
oh about
10 years ago you just opened things
now you unbox things
there's a whole sport to it people
watching stuff okay
look at this gorgeous packaging man and
look who's right there
on the spine as it should be um
gorgeous piece of artwork uh a new piece
of artwork
this is the o-ring of course the o-ring
this whole face
slip it out it's gonna get dirty kids
slipping it out
and look it's inside it's the same thing
so here's your o-ring
uh suitable for
framing and signing check this out so
inside
look at all the mall racks action two
discs
but you can do this let's say you're
like hey man
like i don't want the newfangled artwork
i don't want a drawing
i want my [ __ ] classic i want my [ __ ] to
look like
drew struzan and god intended ladies and
gentlemen
so you could flip the art around kids
watch this flipping the yard around
and suddenly classic mall rats 25 years
ago
that's the image we thought would sell
this movie
and if it's good enough for people of 25
years ago in the 90s
is good enough for this audience but so
you could go choices you can go this
you do both you can get your own ring
here and then like as you open it up
which obviously couldn't do
people like what up it's like two um
they got descriptions on the back of
each so let me tell you what they got
here
limited edition contents brand new
restoration
of arrow films of io films of both the
theatrical
and extended cuts of the film approved
by director
kevin smith and cinematographer dave
klein dave's got initials at the end of
his name asc
um to uh let's see what else
so first off that means like the best
looking version of the movie
ever including the best-looking version
of theatrical and also the best-looking
version of that
dopey long-ass cut that we did years ago
which is all on here
the tv cut of the movie featuring
hilarious over dummy
dubbing to cover up profanity that's
right jason muse
was supposed to come in and you know do
jay's voice
three times he was scheduled three times
he blew off the record
so on the third go around uh the person
who's in charge of doing the dubbing
because if you're doing a tv
version of a movie and believe it or not
somehow they did a tv version
of mall rats uh they did it when
armageddon was out because they were
like you know before
ben affleck saved the universe he was at
the mall that was like the commercial
so they needed a cut and they needed a
timely and jason
you know was irresponsible so he didn't
get
to new york to do the dub to do his own
voice to dub himself over
so the person who's in charge of the
project said just grab that guy
grab the guy on the sound board it don't
matter and so they had some dude who
worked in the
in the lab in the sound studio go like
snoozy boogies and [ __ ] like that it's
crazy so when you watch it
you see you hear jason sometimes and
then you hear somebody completely
[ __ ] different
uh let's see what else they got high
definition blu-ray
presentations collector booklet
featuring new writing by philip kemp
um fold out poster featuring replica
blueprints for
operation drive-by and operation dark
knight
uh reversible sleeve featuring
original and newly commissioned artwork
by
robert samelin so robert samelin did
this which is a gorgeous [ __ ] piece
robert if you got the original artwork
i'll buy it off
uh and then on disc one you get the
theatrical cut of the movie
um which you know has everything on it
including the old commentary track audio
commentary track with kevin smith scott
moser uh
vincent pereira jason lee ben affleck
jason muse
brand new introduction to the film by
kevin smith
uh my male rats memories
uh and all uh a new interview
with actor jason muse i'll watch that i
wonder what his own
what maulrat's memories is he have he
won't remember anything
he was high um let's see what else we
got
brand new interview with cinematographer
dave klein i'll watch that hollywood of
the north a newly produced
animated making of documentary featuring
minnesota crew members
who worked on the film how interesting
deleted scenes kevin smith and vince
pereira discussed deleted scenes and
sequences originally cut from the film
outtakes and behind the scenes footage
cast interviews from the original
set i want to watch those see young kev
smith age 25 being like
too cool for this [ __ ] i'm so emo
um erection of an epic the making of all
rats that came from like the 15th or
10th anniversary dvd
uh q a with kevin smith archival q a
film for the 10th anniversary
mind you we're now on the 25th jeez
louise
build me up buttercup video stills
gallery theatrical trailer
and on the disc 2 they got extended tv
cuts
um and they got the soundtrack epk raw
dailies
raw dailies man you cut your own version
of all right [ __ ] kevin smith make the
movie you always wanted to make with
mall rents
stills gallery of the comic books
featured in the film's opening sequence
easter egg brand new introduction to the
tv cut by kevin smith
probably me explaining like i already
did just here man
that's packed thick as a dick this
[ __ ] blu-ray
25 years kids that's how it's got to be
all right so here you got disc
one and
disc two look at that beautiful man
blu-ray with all that information
uh let's pull out let's pull out let's
see we got here
this is the brand new beautiful booklet
in question so you have all the
amal rats artwork now this was used on
the laserdisc
this was a theatrical pre-release poster
and if you look real closely it actually
says mall rats
not like in the movie where it's like
it's a sailboat and it's just some
triangles and [ __ ]
so look at that i remember posing for
that picture
you it's us doing batman and vicki vale
in case people are too young to remember
that um
cast and crew list
uh mall rats the perfect example of a
sophomore
slump by philip kemp there's a little
essay in there
um one two three four pages how nice
like you know i forgot like back in the
day
criterion and stuff they don't have the
filmmaker write something they're like
let's ask somebody who's not
involved with the film i feel like this
is that's really cool i haven't had this
done
in a while normally i'm the one talking
about my own work that's the reason you
still hear about me because i'm always
out there going kevin smith
philip kemp is a freelance uh reviewer
and film historian a regular contributor
to sight and sound in total film
those are bougie filmmakers and teaches
film journalism at the university of
leicester
he recently edited cinema the whole
story and on the back page here they put
for stan how beautiful is that
on the book about the restoration wall
rats has been exclusively restored by
arrow films
and is presented in its original aspect
ratio
of 185 to one kids with 5.1 audio
the original 35 millimeter camera
negative was scanned in 4k
resolution at nbc universal studio post
facility
a 35 millimeter inter-positive element
was also scanned in 4k
for the content unique to the director's
cup version uh the film was graded and
restored
at r3 store studios in london
this rest london man they took ball rats
overseas and stuff
to blighty this restoration has been
approved by director kevin smith
first time here or another i'm kidding
of course i approve it i'm like the
moment i said you got blanket approval
you wanna have sex with my wife go ahead
you've got my approval i said uh and
director of photography dave klein he
actually did watch it and stuff because
he told me he's like i went through the
restore it was great
um all materials of this restoration
were made available by nbc
universal um well a little bit from
kevin co
because i did the interview here special
thanks kevin dave klein for their
generous participation
on this project well thank you special
thanks to arrow for even doing it in the
first place man
uh and look is that there's that image
of us going down the highway
with suzanne uh and then of course
there's this as mentioned
blueprint if you never bought these from
jay and salam bob's secret stash
or your local comic book store they got
a small one
with a small one like me i got a small
one i got a small one here they got the
blueprint so you can
suitable for framing or tacking on your
wall as we used to do
in the 80s and 90s because we couldn't
all form framers
like i can now i guess that was being
oddly personal
uh and then what is this a little card
for uh watch your favorite cult classics
on the arrow video channel
with with the apple tv app oh my god
i've got apple tv you mean they got a
channel
i'm gonna check them out uh these arrow
kids
you know they're the best right like
they're doing the lord's work in
in home video man they're like shoulder
to shoulder with criterion for heaven's
sake
they make a filmmaker feel
like a filmmaker and with this set they
really did it been 25
years kids i don't want to wreck the
packaging oh my god
how come i can't get the o-ring on this
is like you're getting a peek into my
sex life i'm like i can't get it in
there it's in uh what a wonderful
package what a wonderful
uh uh honorarium if you will how nice to
be memorialized with a fat ass
arrow dvd a blu-ray rather um when that
movie came out
kids everyone was like you shouldn't
have made it like how dare you and stuff
i got
[ __ ] on for that movie and here we are
25 years later and
nobody's shutting on my rats anymore
well i'm sure there is people there are
definitely people probably shooting on
my rights that i just don't cross
paths with but generally speaking
everyone i encounter in today's world
that
they like this movie thank you for
liking this movie for 25 years
that's how we get the sweet ass arrow
blu-ray treatment
kids uh so there it is enjoy
your the [ __ ] night is this wednesday
thursday
wednesday yeah wednesday wednesday
enjoy your wednesday kids uh and the
weekend if it is longer if it's friday
and i suddenly forgot
uh don't forget mall rats available from
the good folks at arrow
uh video um it is look at that i love
that they put me on the spine
um as it should be um it's i
i've heard sold out in some places but
i'm sure you can
find a copy online i'm now actually
going to go roll it and watch it myself
on my big ass tv
um thanks for hanging out thanks for
liking this movie forever so long
and enjoy the rest of your day
you